Hey, thanks for making time.
Did you have a chance to read through my email?
Absolutely! But before we dive in, I wanted to ask:...
You're usually pretty quiet during our team meetings...
...and then you follow up after, like today.
I would really love to see you more engaged in those meetings.
What do you think holds you back?
I know. It's just... in production, we're very process-driven.
I like to get my head around things before I say too much.
Okay.
And you seem so psyched about things.
I didn't want to be a downer in front of the team.
I totally get it.
Sometimes, I'm overexcited.
But the numbers show that our old approach isn't working.
I'm hoping this new approach can get us back on track.
I get that, we do need a new approach.
So, why don't we do this:...
Why don't I make sure that you have a little more of a heads-up...
...before I roll out something new.
That'd be awesome.
And maybe you can jump in a little more...
...even if you haven't quite thought it all through.
Okay, I can do that.
Perfect! And if you think of anything before the meeting...
...you can always send it to me and I can be sure to add it to the agenda...
...so we can be sure to discuss it.
That'd be great.
I think that works for everybody.
Nice.